[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today AA is
with us A's in Washington DC hi Aya
what's up hi Mr Ramsey hey um I was
wondering if we should pay off our
current mortgage and relocate for a
current cheaper
mortgage what's making you ask that
question wait pay off your current
mortgage a or
relocate and get a cheaper mortgage what
would be cheaper than paid off
mortgage um so we bought a house that
needed to be fixed up so we fixed it up
and now it's we just had a realer come
out and tell us what we could list it as
my husband was in the military and just
got out and his job fell through so it
kind of shook us and we just wanted to
move somewhere with the proceeds to have
a cheap enough mortgage to be covered by
my
disability okay um so you're not you
don't have the opportunity to pay off
your mortgage you're talking about
moving to a less expensive property
because you're scared about his
income right why do you think he's not
going to get an
income um it's not so much that he
wouldn't get one we're just um kind of
thinking about reprioritizing our time
the house that we bought is a historic
house so it takes a lot of Maintenance
we do a lot of the work
ourselves that's a different discussion
what do you owe on that
house uh 490 490 I already don't like
the house I hate that we have spent so
much time on it we can get some good
money for it and get something I like is
a good reasonable move I'm using his
lack of a job and a cheaper mortgage as
my excuse is not
okay okay um you see the difference
we're just kind of we're both yeah we're
both on the same boat so we're just you
know the boat where he doesn't
work just that he has more
flexibility and we're not
much how old is he not right now how old
is he we're 25 and 26 okay he needs to
get a career
darling it's not good for him to not
work much I'm not saying he won't work I
am saying he needs to get a career where
he
works okay I'm hearing the code words in
your language 100% he's not wanting to
work much at all and that's worrying
part of it is he got knocked out of the
saddle and didn't get the other job and
it's he's lost some of his confidence
and you're clearly worried cuz you're
talking about selling your house and
relocating so that you could only live
on your disability like you said it with
your own
words I don't think think that that came
out right we he wants to work that's not
the issue the issue is is that we want
to be more flexible with not having to
deal with the house and not having a
mortgage that's so high is the mortgage
more than 25% of your take-home pay it
is now that he's not working but before
that was it no it wasn't no it wasn't
okay okay so your mortgage amount is not
your problem the house if you want to
get rid of a house that's a money pit
where you work on it all the time I
don't blame you I would do that okay but
let let's not couch that in he wants
more flexibility and when I'm talking
about his job your answer is he wants
more flexibility it wasn't when I was
talking about the house repairs you said
that so I didn't I didn't misunderstand
you you said it real clearly so what
what we need to do let's let's let's
parse this out and break it up number
one the two of you need to get really
good cool strong careers that you're
passionate about I will send you a copy
of Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose number two it doesn't sound like
your mortgage is off me neither and I'm
I'm actually wondering number three I
would sell a house that's a money pit
and I had to screw with it all the time
it Dro me nut that's true but I don't
know that if it's a money pit that's one
thing but I don't know I'd be interested
to know more she's in Washington DC
where does she plan on
relocating where she's going to they may
be move into a whole different city too
that's possible but yeah which would be
less expensive for sure yeah I'm getting
rid of The Money Pit but I'm also
getting a career yeah they need and
probably getting a house about the same
price range that in The Money Pit mhm
when I make the move that's would be my
advice to you guys don't don't mix these
things together and create some kind of
false narrative that's not really going
on okay that's what I heard you saying I
think you were saying it whether you
wanted to or not